well here in Germany a court has
sentenced one of the world's most
prolific serial killers to life in
prison
former hospital nurse niels hoga has
been found guilty of killing 85 patients
in his care
prosecutors said that he deliberately
induced cardiac arrest in patients so
that he could then resuscitate them and
impress his colleagues but many of
hoboes interventions failed and patients
died he had already been serving a life
sentence for two previous murder
convictions from his killing spree which
lasted from 2000 until 2005 we're joined
now by our correspondent Marielle Muller
who is at the courthouse today so first
of all how did he react and also the
relatives who were also there in the
courtroom
well needs huugle he seemed very quiet
and calm he didn't show any of his
emotions he was pretty emotional as
actually there was his behavior
throughout the whole trial only
yesterday he read a written statement
saying that he felt sorry and ashamed
and that he hopes that the families
would find peace at some point but I
talked to my talk to members of these
families and they told me no we can't
believe any of what he's saying he has
proven too many times throughout the
trial that he is a constant liar and yes
yeah the victims families reactions
actually they were pretty pretty sad
pretty upset during during the reading
of the verdict they even had to leave
the courtroom to console each other
Mariel just walk us through here because
I mean he was convicted of murder but
the court also accepted the fact that he
wanted to save the patients yes Sonia
Togo injected medicine to his patients
in the first place which may kill them
so then he could come to the to the
scene and be the big hero to reanimate
them and to save them actually but a lot
of times it didn't work so they just
died and he was fully aware of that he
actually used his patients only to make
himself better and to feel to make
himself feel better
so also that's that was the motivation
behind it and that's also why judge
Berman said that there is a particular
sense of guilt which which is given that
means that after 15 years of jail he
might have to stay longer in prison and
if you compare it for example to the
u.s. there were 85 murders and for each
murder 15 years that would make 1,200 70
years so this particular you know guilt
which is here
I'd also talked about this feeling of
how it is to work with this kind of
person for a long time to crank locks
them and a former colleague I met him a
couple of days ago take a look Frank
locks the man still reflects on the time
working alongside needs sugar
the former nurse was his colleague for
two years at the main clinic in olden
book locks Thurman quickly became aware
that there was something wrong with
huger it was obvious he wanted to be the
action hero who saved people you
sometimes get that people who work in
rescue services who are under the
illusion that they're the big heroes
Google is one of those ed and I he log
stubborn only became suspicious after
around a year and a half that's when he
started to notice that patients would
suffer cardiac arrests more often when
hygge was on duty at first we just
thought it was bad luck until a
colleague said so death who go on duty
again despite rumor circulating neither
lobstermen nor any of his colleagues
reported it to the police he did tell
his superior about it though when he
noticed that a patient had elevated
levels of potassium in his blood but
there was no consequences it was later
discovered that Hugo would inject
patients with potassium in order to
bring on cardiac arrests so that he
could reanimate them and appear as the
great life-saving hero again and again
and then on a single weekend on Huckel
shift there were 14 resuscitations and 5
deaths and yet who they will simply
transfer to another ward a new clinic
light on the reason why a clinic
director a chief physician or a nursing
director stays silent is
prevent the reputational damage to the
clinic because we all know that that
would mean fewer patients coming into
our care i'm luciene and in billion
thank you it took several further
resuscitations and the new ward for the
head of the clinic to decide that huugle
had to go now the nurse is alleged to
have killed 36 people by this point he
was dismissed from his post with glowing
references he then applied for a job at
a clinic and Emin house just a few
kilometres away where he continued to
murder unabated 64 more patients were to
die at who could send their Christian
Mabus grandfather was one of his victims
he underwent a gastrointestinal
operation shortly before he was to be
released
he suddenly suffered a cardiac arrest my
grandfather was resuscitated by the
murderer and then 2 or 3 days later the
same thing happened again so he was
practically murdered twice in 2005 fuga
was finally caught red-handed as he was
about to administer an injection to a
patient it was the end of a killing
spree unprecedented in Germany a nurse
who doesn't help sick people but
secretly murders them possibly in more
than a hundred cases reaching these
verdicts we have achieved as much
transparency as is legally possible the
hope now is that many of their relatives
find peace still the legal proceedings
have not yet been completed fellow
nurses doctors supervisors who among
them was complicit in near to those
crimes the investigations are ongoing so
Mariel tell us a little bit more than
about those investigations who exactly
is being investigated and for what so
for now charges have been filed against
two doctors one nursing director and his
deputy and the accusation is that they
knew what Neil's hygge was doing they
knew that he was actively killing
patients and they didn't stop him they
didn't intervene so that he could
further kill even more and continue his
killing spree
and the dodge women clearly said that he
also had the feeling that there was a
cover-up so during the trial when he was
asking witnesses they wouldn't answer
you know in a way which was credible to
him
so now four witnesses are actually also
facing trial for perjury and so the
question still remains who knew what on
which level of hierarchy in these two
clinics and so yeah this is up to
investigators to determine Miriam Euler
in Oldenburg thank you